a menudo se les describe como los
muertos vivientes' drogadictos que
caminan por las calles de la zona en
busca de su próxima dosis siempre
necesitas más nunca es suficiente me
avergüenzo a las afueras de parís en el
noreste de la capital el tráfico es un
negocio que funciona las 24 horas del
día para desesperación de los residentes
locales
cuando evacuaron el área de la carretera
de circunvalación enviaron una bomba
hacia nosotros un simple paseo alrededor
de la manzana da una clara idea de la
situación todas las personas que están
cerca de esa pared o tiradas en el suelo
son drogadictos el barrio se ha vuelto
tan sucio nunca he visto nada como esto
nunca estas son personas nuevas y son
muy agresivas y cada día llegan más
nuestros hijos están asustados
aquí hay una muestra del material que
capturan regularmente al pie de sus
edificios las peleas entre adictos
algunos incluso se abren camino a la
fuerza mientras que otros rompen los
vidrios de los vehículos esto es muy
típico roban un vehículo y luego lo
traen aquí y duermen en él y también lo
hacen con nuestros carros una mañana mi
madre bajó y encontró adictos durmiendo
dentro del suyo el asiento de mis hijos
había desaparecido se sabe que algunos
residentes se les acabó la paciencia y
decidieron tomar el asunto por sus
propias manos incendiando vehículos que
se han convertido en un punto de reunión
de adictos con la esperanza de que se
vayan el tema de la cocaína crack no es
nuevo en parís pero hasta hace un año
estaba casi oculto la mayoría de estos
adictos se reunían aquí entre la
circunvalación norte de la ciudad y la
autopista un área que había sido acuñada
como craft hill el campamento fue
desmantelado en diciembre de 2019 y una
cerca alta ahora mantiene a la gente
fuera mientras tanto el tráfico continúa
moviéndose de un lugar a otro como
consecuencia de cada nueva operación
policial pero siempre manteniéndose en
dos distritos de
e incluyen la zona de laporta doberti es
como un juego de ping pong entre los
alcaldes de los distritos 18 y 19 el
problema va y viene y los residentes
quedan atrapados en medio y estamos
agotados con todo este y los efectos son
palpables el dueño de esta tienda perdió
la mitad de sus clientes ni siquiera sé
cómo describir los lo primero que hago
cuando llegó por la mañana es ponerme
una máscara y recoger sus heces y luego
están los gritos molestan a la gente y
simplemente se vuelven insoportables
por la noche su número aumenta más hasta
varios centenares de adictos se reúnen a
lo largo de este tramo de dos kilómetros
del noreste de parís cuando me levanto
vengo aquí y aquí es donde están los
traficantes a donde más podría ir este
padre de siete hijos de 57 años ha
estado fumando crack durante años perdió
a su familia después de dejarse
arrastrar por este derivado barato de la
cocaína y regresa aquí cada noche
dos tres veces y eso fue todo me
enganché míreme ahora el crack te drena
lo más difícil es cuando se termina
cuando se acaba la gente describe esa
situación como una agonía
es por eso que es tan difícil dejarlo
incluso es difícil salir de aquí cuando
te quedas sin dinero buscas más dinero
porque no quieres irte su adicción lo
llevó primero a cahill y luego a casi
todos los pequeños campamentos montados
y desmantelados uno tras otro por las
fuerzas policiales para él y uno de sus
amigos el desmantelamiento de la colina
significó quedar totalmente
desorientados teníamos doctores que
venían a vernos voluntarios que venían a
examinarnos y los trataban si era
necesario y ahora
ahora todos están dispersos es
complicado no podemos escondernos más
tenemos que sacar nuestra dosis a la luz
del día
y eso es exactamente lo que la policía
pretendía desorganizar el tráfico y
dispersar tanto a los traficantes como a
los adictos esos oficiales han hecho 230
arrestos y confiscado más de 2.000
tortas de crack en el último año ya ha
sido acogido por un centro de
rehabilitación si quería mejorar
conseguí una cita con el medio entonces
aquí está tu oportunidad a esto le
llamas vida aquí tienes un pastel de
crack y una pipa y como pueden ver
estamos hablando de una pequeña cantidad
así que no siempre es fácil de encontrar
para los oficiales según está jefa de
policía el tráfico no ha disminuido pero
al menos no ha crecido más no es un
problema para los residentes locales
ahora que están dispersos no le parecía
un problema tener a 100 personas en
crack
viviendo bajo una carretera circular
rodeada de ratas significa esto que los
residentes del noroeste de parís quieren
que restablezca más crack
si ahora es visible es cierto pero
también lo son nuestras operaciones
policiales y arrestos y hace posible que
nuestros oficiales hagan un arresto y
atrapen a los sospechosos de francia
mientras que en crack en la operación no
se podía hacer con sólo tres oficiales
como se hizo aquí para las fuerzas
policiales la solución no puede depender
únicamente de ellos también se necesita
una respuesta social y médica y sobre
todo quieren que los centros de adicción
se instalen lejos de las zonas de
tráfico de la ciudad una crítica
implícita a la alcaldía del país que a
su vez rechaza la decisión de la policía
de desmantelar cahill calificándola de
prematura en describiéndola como si sólo
hubiera empeorado las cosas
evacuar la colina en esa etapa
básicamente destruyó el trabajo que
habíamos estado haciendo allí y se
repite la misma historia es muy difícil
restablecer el contacto con la gente que
habíamos estado ayudando en la colina y
que ahora está dispersa se invirtieron
nueve millones de euros en un plan anti
crack pero su aplicación se atraso sobre
todo por la amplitud de la crisis
sanitaria y el confinamiento en los
próximos meses se abrirá un nuevo centro
de consumo supervisado de drogas pero
una vez más en el norte de la capital
[Música]